الله اكبر الله اكب الله اكبر السيله
الوحيده في قطاع غزه هي العربات التي
تجرها الحيوانات لانه لا حياه في غزه ضايل
انا احمد السواركه عمري 27 سنه اجينا على
رفح نشتغل على الكاره شردنا من الحرب هي
لقينا الناس مقطعين ه لا في سيارات زي
الخلق ولا حاجه السيارات اللي انت شايفن
على السيرج كلهم كلهم على السيرج فيش سلر
في ترمبات ولا في حاجه هي رجعوهم ل 200
سنه ورا في
الحرب هيك شايف الناس لا عارف تركب على
كاره ولا عارفه تركب حتى الكاره في في
وسع سلار فيش بنزين فش فراحوا الناس تجوا
لين يلتقوا لقصه القاره اللي هي بتطلع ايش
بتوصل الناس وبتجيب الناس الجوالات بعناها
عشان الواحد بس يوفر مصاري يقول يروح ويجي
فيها انه بس نشتري
اكل غير تشهر يا
حجل كله يمشي كثير بطلع مع ناس مرض وبودي
على المستشفى جو كمان وبطلع هنا وهنا بجيب
مرض الناس كثير الله ل الناس الله ربنا مش
عار اقول والله اللي شفته شفت كثير الناس
شفت حات كثير والله جبت كذا مره مع
المستشفى ومن هنا وناس قاعده في الطريق ما
حد قادر يشيلها يعني حاجات كثير بنشوف
جبنا مصابين وجبنا جرحه اول حرب جبت مصاب
وجبت جرحه معز كمان اول الحرب والله جبت
مصابين ومن الشرقيه جبت مصابين ومن الشيخ
ناصر جبت واحد مصاب برضه جبت كثير مصابين
على
الكاره سلطان بلد فرازين حي السلام كندا
انا تقريبا كل يوم بقى في ساعتين عشان
الاقي مواصله توصلني لمكان عملي بلاقيش في
الاخر بجا يش للكره والحماره ايش بدنا
نسوي فيش لا سولر ولا في بنزين ولا في في
ادنى ادنى مواصله انك تتعدي يعني كل اللي
بعدي كله هنا يا اما بتلاقيه مليان اكم من
سياره اللي شغاله والشغالين على الزيت
كمان وتخنق وانقتل من بيحه
الزيت الشغلات الميدانيه اذا ما كانت
قريبه ما بنقدر نغطيها لانه زي ما حكيت لك
بدك تطلع الكار والحمار تروح تغطي فبكون
بيكون ايش الحادث انتهى من من من يومين
ساعه الا ربع يمكن في الطريق بس انا بقول
لك والله الكاره برضه وفرت على الناس
حاجات كثير واحيانا بتاخذ واحيانا ما
بتاخذ برضه اكذب عليك والله يعني بتحمل
كمان القار اكثر وبنقول يلا ايش بدنا نسوي
ما هو برضه ما فيش ومشي ومشي والله الناس
تعبت من المشي انه اخذ منا راقات واخذ منا
تعب والله يعين الناس كمان ويعين الحمير
الح والله يعين الحمير والله صحيح الله
يعين
الحميه بالنسبه لاكل الدواب غالي والله
العلف المواشي غالي لا الدواب لاقي تاكل
ولا البن ادمين لاقي تاكل رسم الله يكون
بالعو يعني البن ادم مؤاخذ واحد بدبر حاله
بس الدواب في شعير له مقطوع الشعير والقمح
المتوفر والقمح بيمشيش مع الدواب بيعين
منه